[Music]
gold born pure and Immaculate in the
heart of dying Stars gold has captured
the imagination of mankind since time
immemorial what enrapturing magic lies
in that soft yellow luster why has gold
Enchanted so many for so long with its
soft pillowy glow and warm gentle yet
firm Embrace what Mysteries lie in Gold
if we dare to follow it down the
Forbidden path into the delicate folds
of gold sweet hey is is this getting
weird for anyone
[Music]
else gold
gold I can't be the only one who's
getting spammed with ads on the subject
of gold right whether it's overol
YouTube spots or Tik Tock Finance guys
pushing their trading courses a lot of
people seem to want me Dan Olsen
specifically to buy gold most ads for
Investments are fairly similar and just
kind of wash into the background
radiation of daily life but this one
caught my
attention I'm going to tell you a story
far more
incredible than I ever
imagined there's nothing else like it
aeric
of
nature I'm
talking about gold and as his wor that
is the suicide squads own Idris Alba
headlining a YouTube documentary on gold
distributed by the world gold Council
whoever they are I'm assuming they were
the villains from Captain Planet gold a
journey with Idris Elba promises to take
the viewer on an eye pleasing Globe
spanning Adventure peering into the
fascinating and complex relationship
between humanity and elements 79 the
ways gold intersects with history and
technology and the result is well I'm
not going to bury the lead here this is
Corporate propaganda it is not
particularly good but its existence is
interesting these kinds of celebrity
hosted corporate spin pieces are a bit
of a relic in this day and age usually
relegated to Industry trade shows or
maybe looping on a screen in the back
corner of some Regional Museum's geology
exhibit the mineral Journey sponsored by
the world gold Council you know that
kind of thing what's unusual is how hard
it's being pushed to a lay audience if
you even glanced at something Finance
related lately odds are you got pushed
the trailer as an ad what is it about
gold that's got us so hooked there's no
sticking one in your pocket and getting
out of it is
there
[Music]
now first of all in the abstract a
documentary about gold is exactly the
kind of thing that I'd watch gold is a
genuinely compelling subject worthy of
exploration especially by a documentary
team with like a travel budget and at
least some access to the operations of a
working mind you could fill the running
time of a documentary just discussing
the chemical properties of gold its
resistance to corrosion its malleability
and how those Elemental traits those
quirks of physics and chemistry inform
its place in culture gold is at once a
practical and useful metal but also a
social construct an IDI form that
connects its actual uses and various
imposed social meanings any
comprehensive answer to the question
what is gold unavoidably carries an
emotional component and that is a
complex thing to unwind so here's some
fun facts about gold gold is incredibly
resistant to corrosion the main threats
to things humans build and use are
oxygen water salt and UV radiation and
gold is for all intents and purposes
immune to all of them it neither rusts
nor rots and aside from Instagram
influencers nothing eats it gold is
pretty rare of the 94 naturally
occurring elements found in Earth's
crust gold is ranked 75th making up 4 *
10 -7% of the crust even though it is
rare in terms of the total mass of the
Earth its global distribution is
widespread with significant deposits on
every continent also relatively rare in
the context of the mass of the Earth
still means warehous is full of the
stuff in human terms despite this Rarity
gold has historically been rather
convenient with nearly pure gold nuggets
being found in surface level deposits
rivers and former Rivers since it
doesn't corrode gold exposed by the
elements stays shiny and easily
identifiable gold is extremely malleable
to the point it can be formed into
threads a single atom thick and then
those threads can be stretched even
further before breaking it can be rolled
into sheets so thin that they become
semi-translucent while still retaining
structural Integrity it can be polished
so smooth it is the material of choice
when a mirror requires maximum Precision
such as those in space telescopes gold
is hard enough to make useful household
objects out of but soft enough to be
worked with stone tools without smelting
gold isn't consumed by most of the
things humans use it for and can be
readily recycled and repurposed simply
by smelting it into something new St
Edward's Crown could easily be reduced
back to a 2.23 kilo Ingot of gold for a
second time in history after English
Parliament melted the original medieval
Crown in 1649 we did it once before
Charles we can do it again as a result
of all of these Cosmic coincidences
humans have been using gold since
prehistory and its basic
industrialization has been invented
multiple times around the world putting
all that another way unlike basically
every other workable material at our
disposal a trinket made of gold can be
sunk to the bottom of the ocean for tens
of thousands of years and be dug up
functionally unchanged the timeline of
gold is the timeline of geology this
physical trait this resilience gives it
an aure of everlasting value even this
cheap little souvenir bottle of gold
Wafers comes with a little card
promising it is a gift of remaining
value there is a narrative around gold
that starts in its physical properties
but balloons into its own collection of
cultural signifiers its own mythology
and any thorough discussion about gold
will inevitably intersect technology
colonialism war and climate change so
when we talk of gold we're really
talking about three distinct yet
entwined things all sharing a name gold
the element gold The Narrative and gold
the commodity and it is this last one
that is the subject of our conversation
today not everything is Rosy for gold
gold as a commodity faces a number of
challenges some with roots going back
decades and some more modern gold has
dare I say a bit of an image problem
gold for a long list of reasons that are
not what this video is about is a
favorite of conspiracy theorists
Preppers and just really a whole host of
weirdos they hoard it they accuse
governments of manipulating it they
promote it with an Evangelical Zeal
getting ready come
in how do you plan on supporting my
granddaughter young man I'm only 17 sir
what can provide her with the brightest
future a home wrong gold gold
it's never too early or too late to
secure your future with gold gold is
always just to contextualize this for my
younger viewers this is not a lost
comedy skit that's the guy who did
burglaries for Nixon uh Shilling
gold so safe to say nothing attracts a
crank quite like gold and that
definitely impacts how The Wider public
thinks of gold as an investment call
rosin capital and tell them Gordon ly
sent you all right I just want to take a
second just to unwind the facts of this
despite the popularity of gold amongst
people who own Doomsday Bunkers the
rationale that they're working from
isn't unsound if you were an investor
back in the Netherlands in
1635 which asset would deliver a better
return over almost 400 years tulips or
gold in the long run you can be pretty
confident that any gold you have will
still be abstractly valuable in the
indeterminate future so on one hand gold
as an abstract Financial instrument is
unlikely to go anywhere but on the other
hand while gold is a safe bet for your
400-year plan it's less of a sure thing
in your 5-year portfolio gold doesn't
pay interest so it doesn't thrive in the
low inflation low interest climate of
the bull run but it's also less
appealing in our current highin climate
and for the sound money gold standard
Austrian economics crowd gold has seen
heavy competition from cryptocurrency
the majority of the accessible gold has
probably already been mined and after
hundreds of years of panning and digging
we've found most of the easy stuff new
discoveries and new operations are
becoming increasingly expensive as the
documentary demonstrates with breathless
Wonder many modern mines particularly
the big high production mines are
thousands of meters deep and all mines
involve displacing massive volumes of
Rock you feel stressed you feel you know
it's just that that's the idea that
we're going down into
the into the center of the
earth mines are also under increasing
scrutiny the average consumer is more
aware than ever of the numerous impacts
of gold mining there's both
consciousness of the systemic impacts as
well as greater access to information
about working conditions for instance
less than 2 weeks before the documentary
was released a gold mine in Zimbabwe
collapsed killing at least nine miners
so we're going to for now set aside the
question of if these mines should exist
at all whether or not the gold that
they're digging up even needs to be dug
up in the first place and just for a
moment put ourselves in the mindset of a
mine operator we don't need to empathize
with them but we do need to understand
their incentives mine operators don't
dig up and hoard gold like they're
playing Minecraft they dig it up and
sell it
making a profit from a gold mine
requires the company to thread a needle
mining operations have enormous upfront
cost and demand for gold is driven
overwhelmingly by bearish sentiment
elsewhere gold has its best days when
the market is crashing this means that
operating a gold mine can be precarious
and the mine is extremely exposed to the
price of gold even small increases in
the value of gold Translate to massive
profits for the mines and in Reverse
small decreases or lengthy lulls can be
dire gold may be the safe pick in the
long term but in the short term
investment in Gold can lead to a lot of
anxiety enter the world gold Council the
WGC is one of the world's leading
Authorities on gold and you'd hope so
given that the council is comprised
exclusively of major gold mining
companies the organization sole purpose
is to push demand for gold that isn't an
accusation it's not even a provocative
statement the world gold council is
extremely upfront with its objective to
promote the interests of its members who
are again big mining companies the
organization was founded in mid 1987 by
the most forward-thinking mining
companies and they were absolutely
forward-thinking because before the end
of the year Gold's value would begin a
sustained decline that would persist for
the next 15 years these sorts of Lobby
and marketing groups are actually pretty
common promoting not just a specific
company or brand but an entire class of
product and they're all technically
nonprofit organizations as a result the
world gold Council exists in a weird
spot on the spectrum of propaganda they
Lobby governments they spin market
trends and they greenwash mining
activities but their ultimate goal is to
convince serious investors to buy gold
Direct directly and put their money into
gold mines their clients sell literal
gold the WGC sells the idea of gold you
are precious you are brilliant you are
gold you are
gold bro I've been there but gold saved
my portfolio a tip for you thank you for
coming visit invest. gold visit invest.
gold to see why gold is everyone's asset
stability
security
protection you shouldn't have to
choose gold your strategic
Advantage visit gold
hub.com like this isn't online crank
Forum stuff these aren't meme stocks
they don't represent tiny artisanal
Minds that consist of three dudes
sharing the one Jackhammer their main
goal is convincing investors to give
millions of dollars to Industrial
operations that will move millions of
tons of rock they can't have a
reputation for spreading disinformation
so while their job is propaganda they
are considered a reputable source for
research on gold but that doesn't stop
the world gold Council from being
implicated in countless conspiracy
theories typically painting it as a scop
i i long concluded that the world gold
Council exists to make sure there never
is a world gold Council so you can try
but you'll never Escape the cranks well
there's some of us who have suspected
since GLD was uh was put together that
it is really a it's another mechanism
and the tool of the central bankers and
their bullion Banks to uh be able to use
the Public's investment gold to apply it
to hot spots in the market to to keep
the price down that it's a it's another
tool of gold price suppression so gold a
journey with Idris Elba is gold mining
propaganda again don't take it from us
take it from Joe cavaton Chief marketing
strategist for the world gold Council
the documentary was commissioned simply
uh put to support our ambition as an
organization to help the world really
understand the value of gold and and
really the experience of its
transformative power you know we're
going to come back to this interview a
few times it's very interesting but yeah
then he just lists some mining industry
talking points yeah I think there's a
couple of key messages that are in the
film I'm going to just highlight a few
uh the first is that for every one job
that a gold mine produces six indirect
jobs or jobs around the community of
that gold mine get created which a lot
of people don't realize that it is as
subtle as a goldplated toilet the
documentary itself has a bit more of a
deaf hand when it comes to smuggling the
agenda in with the info but not that
deaf to hand these things even though
they mean a lot to the artist but they
actually carry the weight of the money
that they 100% that like you know it's
not like it's ever going to depreciate
it's the same thing buy and gold their
Investments that isn't subtext that's
just text the documentary allegedly
features Idris Elba supposedly going on
a globe trotting adventure to shed light
on Humanity's ancient relationship to
gold in actuality it's a virtual tour of
gold mines that all belong to members of
the world gold Council and each segment
exists to either counter a popular
criticis ISM of the gold mining industry
or pitch the mine as an investment
opportunity ilba visits mines in Canada
and South Africa meets the gold bedc to
Shanti King otom for o22 II in Ghana
gets a tour of a bank of England gold
vault hangs out with famous hip-hop
Jeweler ABS the Jeweler and narrates
segments on mine cleanup gold jewelry in
India the California Gold Rush and a
straightup marketing pitch for gold
prospecting in Peru like just to be
clear every mine credited in the
document mentary belongs to a WGC member
Corporation and they play us all the
hits gold mines Foster local economies
they build infrastructure mining
companies totally clean up after
themselves they're even on the front
lines of battling malaria though on that
note even the doc doesn't bother to
pretend that battling malaria is an
altruistic Endeavor it's because they
lose more to sick days than the cost of
R&D on new
pesticides out of the workforce of 8,000
employees is every month you had about
6,800 of these employees in their
dependent reporting to the M hospital
for malaria and so the Mind decided to
establish a malaria control program it's
hard to overlook the fact that the
documentary's global scope has less to
do with the grandness of the subject
matter and more as a matter of
cherry-picking the documentary is unique
partly because it would be utterly
banale in a different context the film
is composed of a series of four to
six-minute sequences that again would
normally be looping in the corner of a
museum installation the fact that
something so insubstantial is being
pushed so hard is kind of fascinating in
itself they had Idris Elba money and
they chose to spend it on this wow look
how hot that is on that note a common
discussion point about the dock has been
elba's performance it's very strange
there are times when Idris is energized
so today is a very special Ashanti aqu
Day Festival I've been honored to be
asked to be part of the procession and
it is an honor there are times when he's
clearly working hard to sell this
thing into the center of the earth too
it's so exciting it's so exciting this
is the first time I've ever seen gold
being poured and in the sound booth hris
has a very stilted energy it could be a
deliberate choice but it feels kind of
like he's cold reading the script ripped
off a teleprompter that is slightly too
far away but for me and I'm pretty sure
I'm not alone here the best thing about
gold is being able to wear it just for
comparison here is elba's performance in
a different documentary to understand
how club culture has become so ingrained
in our modern lives we need to go back
to a scene that started on New York's
underground it was the' 70s and the city
was suffering Idris has close ties to
Ghana and has spent several years
working to develop a film studio in the
during his trip where he met the Ashanti
king he also met the president of Ghana
to discuss policy and was planning to
bring an upcoming film of his to the
region we could case study my film as a
as a a proof of concept to what extent
this influenced his decision to do the
project we can only speculate but it's
plainly obvious that Idris really turns
up in Ghana and less so in Quebec wow
look how hot that is what we're left
with is a very standard piece of
corporate communication with a celebrity
voice actor and overly dramatic framing
for the most part the documentary is
just boring the doc makes boring
decisions for self-interested Reasons by
way of example India has the second
highest demand for gold after China the
two combined to make up half the world's
demand for gold this makes the world
gold Council very invested in the Indian
gold market so we get a short sequence
in India that udes to the cultural
significance of gold in India this is a
big and genuinely interesting subject
but as will be a common theme the doc
doesn't have time to do interesting the
Nuance significance of gold in Hindu and
Ashanti cultures are flanderized into
this very odd and uniform notion of
respect here's Joe specifically
responding to a question about the
importance of treating gold with
spiritual respect whatever that means
you we come on your program regularly we
talk about gold demand Trends we talk
about the significance of India as a
market pay pay close attention and see
the experience where it just sees a
young couple getting married they talk
in great detail about how it's
significant beyond the doy the wealth
creation or the or the passing on of of
of um of that that doy it's more about
how it fits into their society okay so
what he said there doesn't actually
happen for one Idris isn't there he
doesn't see anything but besides that
the documentary only focuses on the
bride's gold jewelry the dowy isn't
acknowledged at all likely because it's
a complicated thorny topic to throw at a
western audience but this is the essence
of the documentary on the whole by
volume it is mostly tacky but
inoffensive corporate spin on a shallow
engagement with the subject matter but
there are of course issues that are too
big even for propaganda to just admit
the subjects of colonialism and
environment being the two major ones the
doc has a sequence in Johannesburg where
the subjects of race and working
conditions are quarantined the film
seeds some ground on this acknowledging
that historically gold mining may be
briefly intersected with racism Elba
interviews France balini who worked in
apartheid era gold mines and was a
leader of a key minor strike during that
interview the two don't pull any punches
they are Carri no water for the mines we
were not really looked after we were
almost like slaves uh because what they
needed is your labor nothing else
however this film was commissioned by
mining companies
so there's no hiding from the fact no
hiding yeah gold mining played a major
part uh-huh in shaping South African
society during the apartheid years yeah
but with
gold the doc then very awkwardly frames
gold as a liberating Force for black
miners but with gold comes power and
those gold miners they knew that because
you see gold by being so useful gave the
miners a bargaining chip by withholding
their labor and denying the country
access to the gold really the black
community was empowered it's a subtle
reframing of a labor strike not as the
withholding of labor but is the
withholding of product an inert mineral
is stealing the Valor of labor unions
it's very weird we're then abruptly
moved to South deep an active mine in
the region that is making use of remote
Vehicles operated from the surface this
is an interesting novelty and genuinely
represents an improvement in working
conditions for at least some stuff but
it doesn't really seem to follow the
heavy discussion of apartheid but as
they talk about mechanization they talk
about how it has done at least something
for gender equality amongst the workers
and then this segment's purpose comes
into Focus that I ladies who are miners
and crew leaders and then the production
supervisor its purpose in the text is to
absolve the industry by saying here is
what happened then and here is what is
happening now the text argues that
mining companies have fixed the
problem that's already Wild on its face
but even within the dock it's a absurd
one is a serious politically charged
conversation dealing with a subject of
race and systemic exploitation the other
is about the quirks of driving a $5
million RC truck for a day job the
argument does not land at all but the
documentary just moves on with entirely
undeserved confidence that it has
tackled the subject of race in the
global mining sector then there's the
subject of the environment obviously
there is no Nuance discussion of the
environmental impacts of mind where the
companies come out of it looking good so
the Mandate is simple say as little as
possible to Omit issues while playing up
successes so that explains why the New
Zealand segment is the way that it is
but it just sucks it sucks so bad the
topic is specifically on the closure and
restoration of sites mining companies
tidying up after themselves the segment
focuses on the Reclamation of reef and
mine located on the south island of New
Zealand the entire sequence is for
minutes long of which there's maybe 90
seconds of footage of the mine we see
that the main pit has been filled with
water and we're shown the process used
to plant seeds from a helicopter were
then treated to a CG render of what the
site is expected to look like at some
unstated point in the future we close on
some b-roll of Wildlife and we're done
with New Zealand here is the totality of
material on the pit when the mine closed
in
2016 their first task was to f build the
main pit to turn it into a
lake that's nice but still looks like a
mine to
me if I held stock in Oceanic gold I
would be furious anyone with any general
knowledge of mining is going to come
away from this dock certain that this is
a Pit Lake the same toxic corrosive hell
holes that you find in a Tom Scott video
it is a mile wide and so deep that you
could fit the new One World Trade Center
standing upright in it or at least you
could if the pit wasn't halfway filled
with toxic dilute acid it looks inviting
but you wouldn't want to swim in there
that is dark and lonely water it looks
toxically blue and it is it's alkaline
it's got a pH above 11 it would be like
swimming in dilute bleach oh yeah that
water's nice and blue in there but the
reef in pit is not like those pit lakes
and this site is notable for precisely
that reason that's why we're here okay
just to back up for a sec we all know
about Abandoned mines a company would
work a mine until either the mine or the
company went bust and then they would
just walk away in the case of open cut
mines like refton the pits often fill
with rainwater over time to create
artificial bodies of water pit lakes or
Quarry Lakes are exceptionally dangerous
places for a whole host of reasons that
we'll just put up on screen here for a
moment the majority of fatalities at
Landon mines are attributed to drowning
in pit Lakes you may also be familiar
with famous sites like the Berkeley pit
in but Montana Berkeley's Pit Lake is so
contaminated by copper that for about a
decade copper was mined directly from
the lake water this makes the water
toxic and if the pit Lake fills Beyond a
certain point The Forbidden Gatorade
will spill into the general water supply
which is considered generally
undesirable in response the US
Environmental Protection Agency has made
mandated that the lake must never reach
that critical level so the water must be
actively pumped out in perpetuity but
even with that over the years they've
had to just keep making the thing bigger
because it's really hard to keep water
from getting into an existing Lake the
Berkeley pit is a particularly
high-profile example but there are
thousands of pit Lakes out there each
with their own risk factors believe it
or not Tom Scott has even visited half
of them this is not a minor problem this
is one of the fundamental byproducts of
the mining process the thing you are
doing at an elemental level is digging a
huge hole until very recently it was
considered Progressive to enforce what
is called a lock and leave policy mining
companies can leave behind a pit that
will fill with toxic water but they at
least need to put up a fence needless to
say this doesn't do much to mitigate the
harm of these pits once a Pit Lake is
established it's incredibly difficult to
unwind because now you're dealing with
massive volumes of water which is both
very heavy in its own right and does not
much care for where you do and do not
want to go so the solution is simple
don't let mining companies leave States
in a state that will produce a toxic pit
that is a complex multidisciplinary
process so that brings us back to Reon
in 2004 Oceana gold received approval to
operate the reef and mine as part of
this they were subject to heavy
obligations to restore the site upon
closure of the mine which included the
posting of a performance bond that like
a rental Bond was money set aside to
cover the restoration of the land in the
event Oceana went bust an operations
director for the Department of
Conservation praised the company's work
describing it as world class unlike
mining operators in the past Oceana gold
prepared for the closing of the mine
years ahead of time they're one of the
first to make use of a new water
treatment system conceptualized at
Cardiff University by oxygenating the
water before it enters the vertical flow
reactor the ion within the water comes
out of solution turning it a reddish
brown color the iron particulate then
gently settles on a gravel bed at the
bottom of the ponds iron naturally
attracts other metals and so is able to
capture free floating arsenic from the
water the water continues its gravity
fed course through the gravel bed and
exits the system into Devil's Creek
extensive testing has proven that the
vertical flow reactor reliably removes
excess Arsenic and iron from the water
over time the metals will be exhausted
from the latchable area of the
surrounding Rock and the ponds will
continue to naturally spill into Devil's
cig I'm sorry why wasn't any of this in
the documentary the helicopter is not
what makes Reon interesting it's the
ecological restoration that literally
gets into the weeds the Woody material
that we place around the restoration
sites also provide little microclimates
for other species that we wouldn't have
planted ourselves such as these ferns
Reon may be the best example of
reclamation on the planet the world gold
Council must think so otherwise we
wouldn't be here but the dock doesn't
want to dig into the subject of
restoration in any detail because to
celebrate what makes Reef to note worthy
would require admitting that it is
exceptional hey these guys have almost
cracked the toxic pit problem wait what
toxic pit problem it's also hard to
overlook the fact that vertical flow
reactors are being implemented in New
Zealand South Korea and the USA you know
wealthy Nations it's one thing for New
Zealand to strong arm Oceanic gold into
restoring a site adjacent to a national
park but what about countries in the
global South human rights organ
organizations have repeatedly found
oceanana gold in violation of indigenous
rights around their didipio M dating
back to 2007 accusations including
illegal evictions and arson and have
repeatedly recommended that their
license to mine be revoked it was not
and the UN has denounced the unnecessary
and disproportionate use of force
against local residents as recently as
2020 can Filipino residents expect
oceanana gold to implement worldclass
restoration techniques to restore their
land odds aren't great the work being
done at refton is interesting and
important it is exceptional in every
sense of the word the documentary went
to New Zealand to cherry-pick the most
radical project it could find but still
managed to stuff it Up the documentary
is only willing to engage with the
superficial elements of ecological
restoration specifically the tree
planting it's really just
gardening but supersized in its brief
runtime the documentary focuses
exclusively on Aesthetics which is
explicitly not what the restoration
project is about so we're not trying to
hide the fact that we mind here but
we're just trying to do our best to put
it back the community doesn't need the
mines existence obscured they need the
company to clean up their crap and avoid
poisoning the groundwater which is what
they're doing but the documentary would
leave viewers believing that the project
is green washing simply planting trees
around an inevitable Hazard the
documentary manages to misrepresent both
angles of the subject it admits the
actual reason why closed mines are so
dangerous and the meaningful ecological
restoration being carried out at the
site the result is that the
environmental activists are pissed off
the company shareholders are pissed off
and you the viewer are bored this sucks
once the doc is satisfied that it has
addressed all your concerns and made its
case for gold is a thing it's happy to
drop the pretense and fixate on the
financials for the last 15 minutes Idris
is given a tour of the bank of
England I've got an appointment with the
bank's Chief
cashier one of the very few people with
access to its
vaults Sarah John anyway Idris gaw had
gold bullion for a bit before taking a
very brief aside to tastelessly discuss
the 2004 Boxing Day tsunami on the 26th
of December mber 2004 there was a
massive tsunami in the Indian Ocean the
Boxing Day tsunami is the deadliest
natural disaster of the 21st century to
date with over 130,000 confirmed deaths
in Indonesia alone mostly concentrated
in the province of a but in AE there was
something unusual about the community
that helped it to
recover you see most people didn't have
saving
accounts instead they had gold ingot and
jewelry which meant they could quickly
use it as
collateral and start putting their lives
back together so we get that little gold
nugget before immediately moving on to
hang out with a celebrity jeweler abtin
Abassi or abs for short is part of a new
wave in jewelry that began with hip-hop
like you know it's not like it's he
going to it's the same thing buying gold
their Investments the final segment is
functionally an ad for newmont's
operations in Peru which are still in
their speculative stages before the dock
wraps up so the story of gold to me it's
really a love story like all romances
it's had it UPS and its Downs what Downs
Idris what Downs what do you think the
Downs might be here here I've got I've
got my notes ready to go I can help make
a list what are the Downs they are all
part of our relationship with this
beautiful
seductive metal hey is is this getting
weird for anyone else the core audience
for the documentary has received it one
of two ways your standard gold bugs have
love bombed the dock like Crypt Bros and
apes there is a vested interest in the
documentary success as a tool of
propaganda leading to the same types of
astr turf techniques on the complete
other end of the spectrum the crackpot
breed of gold buug has responded to the
film with outright hostility framing it
as at misinformation to distract from
the truth about
gold whatever that may be I'm willing to
bet your coming WGC Gold documentary
will be more like a childlike cartoon
you won't dare to try to choke down some
of these ongoing spicy facts regarding
the current day Canard of modern day
gold price Discovery but for us the
documentary's cardinal sin is that it's
boring a documentary on gold could be
interesting should be interesting but
this is what you get when filmmakers try
to tell a human story through the filter
of Industry the potential is there but
the documentary is Tethered to corporate
interests from which it cannot stray
gold is so culturally significant in
India that it's a pillar of the global
gold industry that's fascinating but if
you really dug into it you'd need to
talk about the whole dowy thing and your
American investors might find that a bit
uncomfortable best just not say anything
just talk about how pretty it is if we
praise Reon water quality then potential
investors might learn about the toxic
pit lakes that we normally leave behind
wait what toxic pit problem so better
just focus on the trees corporate
interests smother the compelling
material grinding it down to its
shallowest form essential material is
absent and what material is there is
inexplicably boring funny thing is that
this isn't even the world gold council's
first crack at this particular Concept
in 2021 they released a miniseries
called the Golden thread wait sorry not
a minseries a landmark immersive
documentary series showcasing Gold's
impact on Humanity's past present and
future the hook for this one was that
they found experts in fields that use
gold in some form or another Aerospace
and the like and then have them talk
about their projects gold is critically
important to make Moxy work for a number
of reasons but it's all the same problem
there are specific Interest being served
you can't just tell a story where gold
is a thematic connector between all
these other interesting subjects you
need gold to be the main character so
the whole thing turns into a parade of
scientists and engineers and artists
talking about their projects as though
the most important thing about it is
that gold is involved like sure we
detected gravitational waves that's cool
and all but let's talk about how
colliding neutron stars just generate a
lot of value what scientists saw that
day was gold being created in Space the
gold created in this Collision will
cycle through the cosmos and perhaps one
day will form part of another planet the
impression isn't that gold is a kind of
unique material with useful and
interesting physical properties but
literally magic and when I say there are
interests being served and all that I'm
not extrapolating these people are very
explicit it's in the Press release the
purpose of the documentary is to
increase the relevance and consideration
of gold in the minds of investors and
consumers alike it's kind of maddening I
get so used to dealing with covert
propagandists who are trying to smuggle
in some ulterior agenda and the world
gold Council just does my job for me
guarded with gold so when the unexpected
happens and the world is in
turmoil you're protected so the thing
that I find compelling here is the exist
of these corporate propaganda pieces
because the fact that someone decided
this was a good project to make that
this was worth the hundreds of thousands
of dollars that would have cost even
outside of whatever Idris elbow was paid
that in and of itself is an indicator
the world gold Council doesn't just
decide to hire a celebrity spokesperson
and plaster his face across the internet
because they're bored they don't make a
documentary about how cool gold is
because they're just like they think
it's neat they do it because there's
something that they think they need to
convince us of it ends up so weird and
stilted because they're trying to talk
about narrative and meaning but those
ideas are completely foreign to the
people who produced this I want to go
back to that interview with Joe C Tony
because it really helps illustrate that
these guys are just living in an
alternate universe so there's this
phrase we're all familiar with at this
point selling shovels during a gold rush
the best way to get rich in a gold rush
isn't to dig for gold it's to sell
shovels it's kind of a dark phrase isn't
it like at a basic level it speaks to
some Grimmer human instincts opportunism
exploitation delusion it's a phrase
about Crash pragmatism in the face of
irrationality you would think that a guy
who represents the interests of the guys
buying shovels would maybe find the
phrase a bit distasteful but these are
capitalists in the purest sense of the
word you know a lot of people fail to
remember that the California Gold Rush
produced a very successful and very
wealthy man that was Levi Strauss
there's a bit in the story about it
really get a good appreciation yeah it's
a fun story to understand and you see
how it's not just about Golden mining
but it's about everything in the
ecosystem around it that brings it to
life yeah and not just about selling
shovels about selling jeans for example
to those that are using the pics and the
axes and you know really kind of there's
no sentimentality here there's money to
be made and the thing is that Joe is
ultimately a kind of shovel salesman
himself like okay on one hand Joe
represents companies who dig up gold
companies who literally buy shovels but
the people digging up literal gold
aren't the metaphorical Gold Rush here
mines aren't Panic buying machine parts
the entire thesis of the world gold
council is that gold the asset is a safe
harbor in a turbulent Market it's not
just a thing for cranks and Weirdos with
5 years of canned beans in their booby
trapped shed gold is for slick El an
Savvy people ordinary yet classy the WGC
wants you to know that this could be you
gold is everyone's asset we live in
turbulent times and the market has been
socially elevated as the one real path
for Building Wealth that's the gold rush
and Joe with his slick-looking celebrity
documentary and calming social media ads
is trying to sell you a
[Music]
shovel
gold
[Music]
gold gold gold gold gold gold gold
gold gold gold
gold gold